the other thing that's happened that you
i'm sure be really really interested is
this
on vancouver island so i'm not allowed
to travel right so i can't get a border
plane
so i can't speak in saskatchewan
manitoba and ontario like i am in
british columbia but i can go within the
margins of my own car
right on the highways of vancouver
island and so i've done a lot of public
meetings all of which have been sold out
no no fee but you know they've
overloaded the building
so that fire regulations come into
effect and all that
but guess what's happened
and i i think many americans will be
interested in that
it's the fundamental christian
churches
that have embraced
our cause
and i've come to learn i've come to
learn and these are ones that are not
even part of the mainstream evangelicals
they're independent
churches who
are taking the bible and here's what our
christianity says according to us and
they have built churches up and down
vancouver island and they all may have
different names and so on but they all
share one thing in common and i was
trying to figure out why this was and
i've spoken in of all of the public
meetings i've done the majority have
been in churches okay because they've
been willing to provide a space whereas
then nobody else in the community has
been willing to participate but here's
what i've learned not only from the
pastors but the people who are adherents
and of course they allow other people
into anybody can come to the meeting
they don't have the members of that
church
any any public can come in it's usually
about 50 50 i'd say of adherents and
others who just were interested in what
i had to say but here's why
most of these churches
are learning
in their bible studies about the early
christian church
now i wasn't so much conquered on to
this as when my wife and i back in the
early 2000s went to turkey
and we traveled to catadocia right in
the center of anatolia
okay you've been and there there are
communities that went underground
physically physically underground cities
okay multiple related cities when i
mentioned this in one of the churches
recently
the place went up
they were all familiar with it and
couldn't believe that a person who was
sort of
well you know most people know me as
well i i believe in the principles and
morality of of of christianity and that
we must have a code of conduct as as a
society in order to really function you
know in a sort of a peaceful reasonable
way
but they weren't aware that i was aware
of the early church and when i spoke
about cappadocia you should see the
people's faces light up because they had
been learning about unlike
the mainstream christian religions who
have not a clue about early christianity
and how they were prosecuted because of
their point of view
that was amazing that's absolutely
fascinating and i have also seen uh it
you know it's really interesting it does
show up uh amongst christians that there
is a willingness to resist some of this
nonsense
i've been a little disappointed um that
jews who
have effectively uh you know taken a
multiple millennium
course in persecution have not rebelled
in greater numbers against the tyranny
that is unfolding across the west
um but nonetheless it is it is
interesting that we that there are these
communities that are not having any of
it
absolutely um and and i'm telling you i
was like right from the north in
campbell river in the northern part of
vancouver all the way down to the
capital city victoria which is on
vancouver island
vancouver is not the capital of british
columbia it's victoria
and every weekend by the way there are
thousands of people who protest at the
legislative building
in victoria organization yeah opposed to
what's going on and two weekends ago
they had 13 000
at the people
in little victoria victoria city itself
is only about a hundred thousand people
yeah
there is about 300 000 people
but they had and are continuing to have
and i've spoken there i spoke to one of
the first rallies there and so it's
amazing to see that
right
even more amazing um i am well familiar
with victoria i've been there
multiple times you know it's a it was a
destination for people who live in the
pacific northwest on the american side
um
so i'm well aware of the place i had no
idea there were protests going on there
i mean it's you know it's a hopscotch
from here regularly and you know
thousands of people and thousands of
people
so how have they managed to keep that
secret
well because the press the game won't
carry it is not carried into times
columnist which is the main newspaper
there right i think one story out of all
of the things right
all of the broadcast media the tv media
so you got to reply on the alternate
media in order to get your message out
and so
people in saskatchewan wouldn't know
and if you if you do pay attention to
the so-called alternative media then of
course there's a a
great list of stigmas that are directed
your
way so you know this is another aspect
of this that i wish people
put more thought into which is we have
no idea actually how many people believe
what and how many people can see the
tyranny um because the intimidation and
the control of our discussion has been
so thoroughly effective
no question and even all the way down to
polling now you can't trust the polls
well you never could trust them all that
much but even less so now in the sense
that people are not going to answer
either answer the phone or if they do
they're not going to give how they feel
because they're afraid that that too
will get uh somehow right okay it was
this many in this region of bc who who
said this according to the poll they
don't want any chance of getting back to
them because they're scared like you
said
yeah no it's uh it is the most
bewildering circumstance right you can
say the most obvious things and suddenly
your life is turned upside down protests
of thousands of people can be happening
well the prime minister called us racist
misogynists
right he said there's
i think he said you know we had to
wonder if they're taking up some space
that they shouldn't be taking up
i recall saying that
right yeah
leaders in the west saying things that
you know if even 10 years ago if you had
had a preview of what was going to be
said you'd think uh prime minister
saying that all hell would be the party
the party would have him out the door he
i was leader of a political party in
this country in the province of
newfoundland and labrador and and i was
a national figure for quite some time
because of my
involvement with the constitution and
other national matters okay and i know i
i know the system in canada pretty well
and then i was a consultant for a number
of years right and so i've traveled in
every single jurisdiction in this
country okay every single one i've done
business in most
i've spoken most okay and i so i know
canada pretty well right and so when you
see now a political party and a country
willing to have a leader and a prime
minister who broke the law five times by
the way
that that's documented five times the
ethics and conflict commissioner of
canada
has produced
reports investigated the situation and
he has broken the conflict of interest
law five times in this country and
because the law has no accountability
except for a hundred dollar fine or
fifty dollar fine he still remains
leader of the political party and he
still remains prime minister of canada
and so when you have a population that's
willing to continue to support somebody
who's broken our laws whereas if you and
i broke the law tomorrow right you know
we would get significant fines or put in
jail or whatever whereas he can walk
scot-free and and and still be the prime
minister's country so there's something
rotten in the state of denmark as our
great bard would say when that can
happen
he had no question about it now you
raised the issue of his violations of
the law
i don't want to miss the opportunity to
ask you about violations of
the constitution that you helped write
i did a quick look through your
constitution um you know it does have a
lot of familiar themes from the american
constitution
and i spotted several things right away
you know even though i'm not a canadian
and i'm less familiar with what has
unfolded there was still clear that
there were several places where your
constitution guarantees rights that uh
were nowhere in evidence
what do you see as the list of uh
violations well the first one you may
not be aware i have taken the federal
government to court myself oh i didn't
know that
yes and that was a that was the other
thing that
i guess
allowed me to be more of the national
figures and when i asked when i did all
these speeches you know one night i came
home and got up the next morning i said
to my wife you know i'm talking the talk
and i know what i'm talking about
because i helped create this document
and i'm on very safe ground and very
confident with what i am saying and
these violations
but one of these days somebody's going
to say to me even though i'm out there
front and i'm risking and i'm doing all
of this on my own tab right and i'm
going all these places do all things and
i won't take any money i won't take any
reimbursement for what i'm doing i'm
doing it as a canadian
and it's somebody who has to give back
as well and and all the right reasons
but the other thing is somebody could
still say you know why don't you walk
the walk
so i contacted the justice center for
constitutional freedoms which is a
organization in canada which just
depends upon contributions from the
public and they take help people go to
court to challenge the government on
constitutional grounds that's what
they're set up to do
so i contacted them and we um decided
with outside lawyers as well
that i would with four or five other
people
take but i was the sort of the chief
claimant take the federal government to
court over their travel mandates whereas
i as a canadian sitting on vancouver
island can't get a border plane in
nanaimo british columbia and travel to
anywhere
i can't travel within my own country or
leave my country unless i'm vaccinated
and so i've challenged
that section six of the charter rights
and freedom which says i have the right
to travel anywhere in canada or leave
canada so i'm actually now my court case
is registered
and there's now the
lawyers appointed by the federal
government who argue their side
and so we're moving through the courts
now and my hearing is likely to be in
august or september of this year
and so i might get ahead of a lot of the
other cases that are in canada
challenging the constitution because
most of the mandates in canada in canada
are provincial and have to go through
the provincial courts first then to the
supreme court of canada mine is a
federal mandate i'm challenging a
federal mandate which brings me into the
federal court of canada then the supreme
court of canada so i only have two steps
to go whereas everybody else
most everybody else has three or four
steps to go so i'm actually out there
front and center actually
in the court
fighting tyranny my my government
fighting
wielding your constitution on behalf of
your your fellow citizens um so let me
ask you a couple things about this um
all right you're on vancouver island
which is part of british columbia
you cannot get on a plane because you're
not vaccinated that immediately causes
you a problem on vancouver island uh you
know i mean exactly i'm i'm on the uh
you know the western part of canada and
five thousand miles away in st john's
newfoundland the province in which i was
born yeah and not only can i go to
newfoundland i can't get on the 911 go
to kelowna or go to vancouver or go to
victoria right um okay so
uh i know that there was a regular
ferry uh
to
i guess there was one to vancouver the
city of vancouver um can you get on that
yes okay so you can go by you can go by
boat i can go by boat buy i got the
mascot i can go by farewell because
they're in that's inter-provincial
we're still in the same problems right
but you can oh so you can't leave
british columbia you can go to vancouver
and go to the maine but no on the ferry
side but i can't even get on a plane and
go to another part of british columbia
okay got it because aviation aviation is
federal under the constitution can you
get to toronto
no i can't get anywhere in canada you
can't
this is amazing
or by train
and um i'm not allowed to take the train
either um
let's suppose
that the mandates
collapse as
uh
attention turns to events in ukraine and
summer uh drives the pathogens here they
are very falling now but the federal one
hasn't gone yet but let's suppose it did
what happens to your court case
stay safe because they broke the law for
all of these days and months before they
lifted it the law doesn't go away by
calendar it goes away by if you violated
it or not right good
uh and then
we're in we're in there to the end okay
and if i lose on the federal court i'm
taking the supreme court of canada i'm
not stopping until i go to the highest
score and then if the highest court
turns it down then i'll have to propose
a different kind of country than we got
now
[Music]